what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with our coverage of the dark
multiverse saga at dc comics and we're
continuing with justice incarnate issue
number two which all of this directly
segues into the events of the dark
multiverse and tells us just how bad
things really are so what we end up
doing here is we basically pick up with
what was initially what we saw at the
end of the last video which is basically
the forces of dark side attacking the
house of heroes that's not going to
become overly important until we get to
the very end of the story just know that
that's still just kind of going on in
the background what is important here is
the justice incarnate remember they're
trying to find the crack in the
multiverse now the crack of the
multiverse is as much a meta commentary
as it is a physical thing it is quite
literally a crack the problem with this
is it keeps transitioning and shifting
around the multiverse and so the justice
incarnate has to chase it around the
multiverse until they finally catch it
the reason why this matters is because
that crack in the multiverse is what
will allow the great darkness to enter
into the positive multiverse and
basically destroy everything right just
annihilate everything in existence and
so in their attempts to find the crack
the justice incarnate actually ends up
finding themselves on earth 13. now
earth 13 is a really interesting
universe it's one that you don't see
very often in dc comics this was
initially given to us in the
multiversity guidebook by grant morrison
the multiversity guidebook is exactly
what it sounds like it's basically a bit
of a story but most of it is just giving
us a quick one paragraph or maybe two or
three sentence explanation on the
different universes that exist as part
of the greater multiverse as it was
created by grant morrison and so earth
13 is a universe where everything is
based on 13 right 13 months and 13 hours
in a day but the other part of this is
that it is a world that is caught in
perpetual twilight it's always dark the
sun never rises here now there is also a
bit of an explanation that's given which
you know is we can kind of basically
talk about it here that when it comes to
the realms between magic and reality
there's a kind of dividing layer there
and in dc comics when it comes to the
main dc universe that veil is pretty
strong and that's why you never really
see much crossover between anybody
outside of like john constantine or
swamp thing with like the rest of the dc
superheroes but in this reality it's all
basically the same thing and so the way
this plays out is that once the justice
incarnate basically get to what is in
effect a secret entrance they utter the
password and they're met by constantine
in this reality who basically like
welcomes them to the tavern a mystery
right now one of the things he says here
is if you're gonna be in this place like
one constantine all these guys here
they're all well aware of the multiverse
and that's one of the things that i hope
you're picking up on is that seemingly
everybody outside of the main
superheroes in the dc universe have a
full understanding of the multiverse and
exactly what's happening out there right
now a lot of it's because they end up
sending members of their forces out into
the multiverse for any number of things
but they're far more involved with
what's happening on a multiversal level
than the superheroes from the main dc
universe but what constantine also says
is let me get together basically the
league of shadows so essentially this
reality's version of what you would call
the justice league let me get them
together explain everything that's going
on while you're here do not drink
anything and do not look at anybody for
too long right because this is a place
where everybody's on edge and a fight
could break out at any moment and given
how powerful some of the forces are here
it's entirely possible that some of
these guys could be killed but one of
the other things that goes on and it's
kind of a funny moment here is you do
have dr multiverse who approaches calvin
right president superman and like she's
digging him and i wouldn't be surprised
if she was interested in knocking the
boots in some capacity now of course he
shoots her down he's like i don't have
time for it i've got more important
things going on and that's when he's
pulled aside by thomas wayne and he's
like look man just a word from the wise
i am a guy who's lost virtually
everything now i was reunited with my
son and i finally get to know that even
if in a different universe my son lives
on and becomes everything that i hoped
that he would become but my wife
martha's lost to me now for those of you
guys who don't know the significance of
that thomas wayne is flashpoint batman
so in his reality which we did cover
that story and we'll link to it down in
the in the description of this video as
well as a card that you'll see pop up
here in the video and his reality in the
flashpoint universe basically the way
things played out is that instead of
thomas and martha wayne being shot and
killed by joe chill it was bruce wayne
who was shot and killed this led to
thomas wayne becoming batman albeit
without nearly the amount of gadgetry
that we're traditionally used to seeing
with batman but martha wayne went insane
and became the joker which was just an
amazing concept in the story and so
ultimately thomas ended up having to
kill his wife and that's basically why
he says like she's lost to him forever
now because even if he hadn't killed her
her brain was just permanently gone
there was no means for her to recover
she was just lost forever and so in
light of that calvin's just kind of like
i mean she is kind of hot right you know
like dr multiverse is kind of you know
maybe maybe we might see what's going on
we might go find a quiet spot and uh
lock some lips you know that kind of a
thing but before he finally gets over to
her he's met by this reality's version
of dr fate now this is one of those
instances when we find out that it
wasn't just machine head on earth 8 and
like yellow lantern joker and those guys
that ceded their world to dark side that
it was actually the guys here who did it
as well but not everybody knew what was
going on that when it came to the guys
on this world they didn't know that they
had handed their universe over to to
darkseid instead they thought that they
were basically staving off any kind of
multiversal calamities that would lead
to like their their universe or their
earth being effective it wasn't until
later on they realized that it was
happening with darkseid now this is one
of the things that i want to specify
here and this is one of the things
that's so cool whenever you think of
dark side in dc comics you usually think
of dark side like invading the main dc
universe that's usually when you always
see him is when he's invading the main
dc universe but this has callbacks to
like the old earth 2 story in the new
52. so in that storyline which we never
actually covered here but we probably
should have it was darkseid who was on
the hunt for his daughter graham but he
was also attacking various worlds across
the multiverse so the earth 2 story was
it didn't really involve dark side
himself he was attacking the main dc
universe at the time it actually
involved him sending steppenwolf to
attack that reality and steppenwolf
succeeded batman ended up destroying
himself to try to stop the parademons
wonder woman was killed by steppenwolf
superman was turned into a parademon the
important thing is that when you look at
that story and you look at this story it
gives you this realization that
darkseid's essence right the fear that
makes him who he is is permeating across
the multiverse everybody knows the name
of darkseid and everyone fears the name
of darkseid they do what they can to
stand against him but knowing the dark
sides out there and knowing darkseid
could be coming for your universe is
enough to send a shiver down the spine
of virtually anybody out there and so
that's why this is such a big deal is
because these guys didn't know they were
ceding their world to dark side if they
had they probably wouldn't have done it
in the first place now initially a fight
starts to break out between fate and
superman but that's when you end up
having etrigan the super demon who shows
up now that's one of the other big
differences here is that unlike having
jason blood who basically made a bargain
with demons and ultimately bonded
himself to etrigan and that's kind of
the other half in the same way that like
bruce spanner becomes the incredible
hulk jason blood becomes etrigan that
what ended up happening here is
etrigan's origin actually mirrors that
of superman where he was sent away from
a dying world he landed on earth and he
basically been there ever since but he
is by all standards of measurement what
you would call this reality's version of
superman that's how far reaching magic
is here everything is based on magical
energy as opposed to magical energy just
being a portion of what you see in the
main dc universe and so of course with
etrigan showing up here this basically
leads to fate just fleeing for his life
and so what you get is etrigan who leads
the justice incarnate to who is
essentially zatanna kind of the lead
magical person in this reality as she
sits down with the entire team and says
we need to stare at the crystal ore we
need to get a better idea of what's
going on out there in the multiverse so
we know exactly where to send you in
order to locate this crack because the
reality here is that they weren't
supposed to land in this universe but
they ended up arriving here instead the
problem with this is that when the
observations are made within this orb
the sheer amount of chaos that exists
out there in the in the multiverse is
enough to basically crack it that this
war that's coming is a colossal of them
it's massive in scale bigger than
anything that we've ever seen with
regards to a multiversal crisis that's
happened in dc comics that's the way
they're building it here and so where
you initially have like all the
different members of the justice
incarnate who were basically set on fire
the reality is that they're being
engulfed by the orb and teleported away
they basically emerge or arrive directly
where the crack is at the problem here
is that when they arrive where this
crack is located it's actually dark side
and asmodal fighting each other now as
model is a guy that we've never really
talked about think of him as like
another version of lucifer that where
lucifer had basically challenged god and
then been cast down from heaven into
hell that following that as model tried
to do the exact same thing that's why he
has the nickname of the angel king the
guy that tried to lead a rebellion
against god or at least another
rebellion against the presence the
important thing to take away from this
is that one this conflict is taking
place at the very edge of the multiverse
before you get to what is in effect the
source the second thing to take away
from here is that this is darkseid in
his true form this is the most powerful
dark side's ever been this guy as modal
is going toe-to-toe with him now you can
extrapolate things here and you could
say okay given this level of dark side
and given the power that osmoto
basically represents you could argue
that darkseid is potentially on par with
lucifer morningstar in terms of power
there's nothing definitive to say that
and you can't take it as an absolute
truth and we're not gonna do that here
it's really more of just inferring this
is potentially what dc is telling us
here but these are two of the most
powerful beings in existence right now
and their fight is extreme so much so
that there's nothing that justice
incarnate can really do here not only
that while this fight's taking place and
the justice incarnate is trying to track
down the crack and locate it remember dr
multiverse can see across the multiverse
see everything in the multiverse all at
once and one of the things she realizes
is that darkseid is not the only person
hunting for the crack though while
darkseid is doing his thing that the
great darkness has servants under his
control and the great darkness has sent
those servants out into the multiverse
to find that crack to bring it to the
great darkness so the great darkness can
enter the multiverse itself and that's
what dr multiverse says is like there
are other servants of the great darkness
on their way here right now and one of
them is literally appearing at this
moment which turns out to be the bat
woman who laughs now i love this concept
i love the idea of an evil batwoman
partly because it's just the most
relevant her character has been in years
and two because i love the concept of
the batman who laughs and i'd love to
see a different variant on it i mean
obviously this is happening because the
general idea of the batman who lives is
just hugely popular but the the
important thing here is that this
batwoman who laughs is not from the dark
multiverse that that woman who laughs is
from the positive multiverse she's from
earth 11. now this is a cool thing
because she's an agent of the great
darkness which means she's empowered by
the energy even if only a small portion
of it of the great darkness itself this
power she possesses is enough that she
overpowers the entirety of the justice
incarnate to the point that they realize
the only thing they can do to keep her
contained is to whisk her away to the
house of heroes to their base of
operations and keep her locked away
there but they don't know that the house
of heroes is under attack from the
forces of darkseid as kind of a
secondary confrontation and so while
this is going on right while that woman
who laughs is just wreaking havoc on the
justice incarnate what ends up happening
is uh calvin president superman tells dr
multiverse send her to the house of
heroes right whisk her away teleport her
away there and the people of the house
of heroes will basically take care of
that the problem is once she gets there
she actually ends up adding to the chaos
as opposed to stopping the chaos and so
as a result of that the house of heroes
has no option but to basically detonate
the entirety of their location because
if the house of heroes headquarters is
taken over by the batwoman who laughs or
even the forces of apocalypse they'll be
able to use the house of heroes to go
anywhere in the multiverse they want to
they'll have an easier job of finding
the crack than like the justice
incarnate because they're currently just
kind of lost in the multiverse right now
and so as a result of that detonating
this basically stops the forces of
apocalypse and it stops that woman who
laughs from being able to find the crack
of the multiverse harness it and use it
and hand it over to the great darkness
and so this whole self-destruct sequence
is initiated the problem with this is
that it has a ripple effect right one of
the things to keep in mind is the
justice incarnate is kind of tethered to
the house of heroes in the sense they
can be teleported back in almost any
point in time but their ability to
travel to the multiverse is anchored
through the house of heroes base of
operations when the house of heroes is
destroyed it sends a shockwave that
affects the justice incarnate and
scatters them throughout the entirety of
the multiverse this is cool because what
we get to see is basically going forward
this kind of tour of the multiverse that
ultimately culminates in them coming
back together and facing off against
what may very well be the single most
powerful being to ever exist in the
history of dc comics which is not true
form darkseid somebody powerful enough
to overcome true form darkseid but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace